a lot of guys are always saying to us
hey we just got this baby how am I
supposed to still have man style when
this thing never wants to go to clubs it
was too small to wear jewelry but being
a father doesn't mean changing who you
are which is a dude who lives to party
some a year baby work for you with our
simple tips you'll be sending your kid
off to cooler mentary school in no time
summa [ __ ] laude for today's episode this
guy is gonna be our baby I'm bring a new
baby home it's important to infant prove
your pad a baby's of no use of its head
falls off you're definitely gonna want
to get a baby gate the ultimate in baby
security because things we use every day
can actually be deadly to your little
one like your cleaning supplies broken
glass or your gun or guns just like guys
babies love chowing down on some tasty
grubbage so does that mean that we can
just give doll some what we're eating
not so fast some food isn't safe for
babies like fajitas
well duh Gabe I'm not gonna give dhalsim
my steak fajitas but how about chicken
fajitas or vegetable fajitas no the
grubbage babies like is called formula
our signature man style formula is milk
with just a little bit of energy drink
test it on your wrist to make sure the
temperatures right but Dolph has puppy
energy now it's made of rep it doesn't
have any energy
sometimes babies get messy for example
looks like dollfie organism fudge that's
a doll you got into some fudge but you
bring up a good point mr. fudge how do
you clean a baby the dish washer dryer
hose toothbrushes you clean it the way
you clean your own self in the shower
now that your baby is clean and full and
safe it's time to decorate it give them
a chain wallet just like Daddy there's
nothing more embarrassing than when your
baby's wallet is stolen one drawback to
having a baby is that a lot of so-called
tattoo artists won't give your baby
permanent ink so try fun henna tattoo
and another common baby accessory is a
pacifier you can find one at pretty much
any rate with a baby this stylish he'll
be beating other babies off with a stick
at no time
now you're ready to raise your baby
right they grow so fast Isles don't grow